wo wir gerade bei europa sind emanuel
makro hat quasi mit uns allen schluss
gemacht hat es mitgekriegt ja aus dem
nichts völlig untergegangen diese
meldung makro hat im elysée-palast
lauter schlimme sachen gesagt über uns
deutschland wäre kein vorbild mehr sagt
er und unsere wirtschaft
exportwirtschaft die auf billig
produktionsländer sei nicht sozial das
stimmt ja alles aber das kann uns doch
nicht ins gesicht sagen ich finde es
traurig und gernot hassknecht auch
gernot hassknecht beweint das
überraschende ende der
deutsch-französischen freundschaft in
nur 133 sekunden man franzosen so geht's
aber nicht einfach schluss machen nur
hermann die merkel mal ein zwei jahre
nicht antwortet auf macros ideen für
europa cup jetzt endlich wir deutschen
haben keinen bock auf ideen und wir
hatten doch einen super deal ihr kauft
unsere autos und wie ihr euren käse der
nach thomas schmeckt klare
rollenverteilung merkel erklärt euch wie
die welt funktioniert wer auch immer
gerade bei euch chef ist sagt artig
genau ja wir verkaufen ganz europa
unsere mit niedriglöhnen
subventionierten produkten
alle müssen sich verschulden und kriegen
von uns dann auch noch kostenlose
oberlehrer vorträge über sparen klar das
klingt manchmal unsympathisch aber wir
können nun mal alles besser als ihr
wissen sie es gibt kleine hotels und
frankreich da kriegt man ein kurs um
einen platz futter und ein klacks
marmelade das ist ja ganz nett aber noch
kein frühstück wir deutschen können
besser frühstücken okay das ist wahnsinn
ein ddr-bürger belehrt einen franzosen
über das essen bei dem zunächst gab es
morgens eine scheibe asbest mit
marmelade diebe franzosen jetzt ist
nicht die zeit uns im stich zu lassen
erstens haben wir sonst keine freunde
mehr
und zweitens sind unsere
vorzeigeunternehmen naja sagen wir mal
unschuldig in not geraten
wir haben doch so viel schönes zusammen
erlebt es lebe die deutsch französische
freundschaft die franken die uns noch
eine chance wir können uns ändern und
wenn überhaupt machen wir schluss mit
einschnitten mensa stolz michael b
schreibt auf facebook wilke du bist der
letzte arsch nur große fresse ich möchte
ich mal sehen wenn es hart auf hart
kommt dann schaust du dir in die hose
warte ab ein sprichwort sagt man trifft
sich immer zweimal im leben mach weiter
so mit einer großen fresse wie können
warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 im zweiten oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren